eh bien, il me semble que vous êtes bien
mieux sans cette subtilité
superjerk biggish blab exactement
super jerk rose noir Rosita dr.
George d'accord ici, il devrait y avoir des
bonbons idiots quelque part là-dedans,
aidez-vous simplement avec ces
tout est tout pour aimer ma
vie blanche
Kyle vous emmène s'il vous plaît sûr Johnny
verre d'accord préparez-vous parce que je vous préviens que
ce Saint est au-dessus de ce nuage avec
grande puissance de cochon reste tellement désolé
et pas de contrôle oh allez ça va
oh oui je vais bien merci
comment vas-tu
je ne chante PAS ce qui ne ressemble pas à
ta femelle et tu es un adolescent
cette chanson était une vache bébé c'est comme toi  peut à l'
intérieur de mon esprit d'adolescent hiney je sais
bien oui je dois juste ajouter
un peu d'humeur et un peu de fou mais voici mon
numéro alors appelez-moi peut-être allez-y
oh vous voulez dire que j'ai dit essayez de me chasser mais
voici mon numéro alors appelez-moi peut-être
là  tu vas tu es un naturel si je
suis sur le terrain je pourrais être soudain alors je
dirais les choses que je veux dire je pensais que
j'avais quelque chose là-dedans
maintenant et [ __ ]
Dixon au fait tu es
Johnny tu étais supposé que nous gardions la petite
ville  désolé gentil je crois votre patron
[  Musique]
penny comment osez-vous que j'aie
étudié comme je suis à la Lincoln School of Music
désolé alors Charlie a obtenu en ce moment oh
c'est si bon d'accord tirez-le faute de
vider vos poches en ce moment bien
qu'est-ce que c'est ensemble
qu'est-ce que tu fumes  de ça c'est bien ha
ha
je sais que vous pensiez tous l'avoir
vu ici - la vie de singe à votre
guise
et la prochaine fois choisissez quelqu'un votre jour
garçon
ouais Dada tu es prêt grand gars ouais je suis
totalement prêt tout le monde dans le  la ville est une
chance d'être absorbée par notre
compétition de claquement merci elle est sur le point d'exploser
avec une puissance de cochon majeure tu bosses
tu es vraiment drôle regarde ça
va parce que je reçois des remerciements pour la cuisine bonjour
mesdames viens ma dame tu es mon papillon
oh  mon Dieu regarde ses fesses oh mon
dieu tu vas bien oh oui je vais bien merci
comment vas-tu si tu voulais venir Stars
et gagner cent mille dollars et tu ferais mieux d'
être prêt à travailler plus dur que jamais
dans ton  la vie oh oui c'était
un sac de beauté quelle histoire
il n'y a pas de Colline où Will  iam oh les
répétitions mais je ne veux pas être en toi les
gars je veux être un chanteur
dodo adulte avec un fils pas toi tu penses que
tu n'es pas impliqué toi je peux penser que
je peux avoir peur rentre chez moi ma confiance
ne pas  tu veux que ça revienne ce qui se
passe ici
oh quelle raison oh une raison toutes ces
capacités manquent d'or ne laisse pas la peur
t'empêcher de faire la chose amoureuse
tu sais ce qui est génial de toucher le
fond il n'y a plus qu'un chemin à parcourir
et c'est
[Musique]
c'est mon fils il n'est même pas si bon
ouais ouais totalement
[Musique]
je suis désolé pourquoi analysez-vous j'en
ai fini ils ont dit que je suis un
égocentrique intolérable je ne sais même pas comme ce
nom si je  sentir que je pourrais être soudainement
je dirais les choses que je veux dire
nous supposons que nous le gardons sur un territoire
que mes théâtres ont traversé
des moments assez difficiles comme faire face que dois-je
faire
non mon prochain spectacle va être batteur
seulement tu chantes des concours le
gérant de l'épicerie c'est ce
poulet mais alors tu tu  rn ça de la vraie
vie en apprenant que vous s'il vous plaît dites-leur de partir
c'est entre vos mains
oh ouais tu étais super chérie par la façon dont
le lavabo de la salle de bain est à nouveau bloqué je
vais gagner c'est vrai c'est à moi
tout le monde dans la ville c'est une chance d'
être une star  sur ma scène ma dame
tu es un papillon
oh mon dieu regarde ses fesses ouais tu vas
bien oh oui je vais bien merci comment allez-
vous les gens disent que tu bosses tu es
vraiment drôle alors on ne va pas
dire  soit
peut-être qu'il est temps de passer à autre chose allez
tu sais combien cela signifie pour nous
tu ne peux pas simplement l'être tu dois
montrer la conception du fichier le feu il
y a une fois tu ne vas pas croire ce que j'ai fait
aujourd'hui et  Je ne veux tout simplement pas être vous les gars,
est-ce que ce sera un chanteur
Zoe Je ne le fais pas avec une tasse de soleil ouais ouais tu
sors neuf attends je vais avoir l'argent je
nage comment pourrions-nous changer la
leçon de piano oui c'était la beauté  jour un
moment déterminant à tous nos yeux
tout ira bien non ouais
[Musique]
ne te laisse pas arrêter tu peux faire les
choses que tu aimes  tu sais ce qui est
génial de toucher le fond il n'y a qu'une
seule ligne allons-y
dans la compétition, tu
penses que ton voisin le
gérant de l'épicerie c'est ce poulet juste
là tout le monde dans la ville a une chance
d'être un magasin en direct sur ma scène mec
viens madame Coco Molly tu es un papillon
oh mon Dieu mais oh mon dieu d'accord  oh oui je vais
bien merci comment
tu vas
[Musique]